pour le moment on va faire une aveo
première fois
attention on se concentre et si vous
n'arrivez pas à répondre aux questions
séverine bouix qui raymond la première
fois tout seul dans ce cas au verso à 6
mois à 6 mois déjà
voilà une bonne réponse
brix je suis moi c'est ce que je me suis
dit vous n'aurez pas que des joker la
première fois avec une fille est rare
dans mes rêves
le premier bisou le voyez bisou à un
garçon un petit bijou d'eau moi je sais
pas imitant luttant oui 57 quand même
mieux qu'hier je crois pas trop parler
maintenant
le premier baiser là pour le coup le
premier vrai baiser avec un garçon et là
on revient deux garçons et la longue 12
ans
le premier flirt poussé poussé jusqu où
un fleurs poussent et ça veut dire un
truc laurent gbagbo laurent la première
fois l'amour pour de vrai c'est à dire
15 ouais j'ai moi même une fille de 15
ans est-ce que je peux poser une
question c'est pas un peu tôt 15 ans
j'ai une fille de 14 ans - oui mais qui
en fait son métier non non
ok
aller dans une école
ça paie trop cher c'est autre chose non
simplement est-ce que c'est pas un peu
tôt c'est un jugement très heureuse et
j'étais prête et jamais je me tape à
voile à quoi allait bien passé quand tu
penses à ta à ma fille j'aimerais
qu'elle attend de 20 à 25 m réfléchi
combien selon charles et des abeilles
avant je lui parlais du pollen il ya
plein de choses on n'a jamais parlé
vient alors le premier grand amour 17
premier chagrin d'amour
ah ouais ah oui je joue qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ça allait pas quoi ils vous
avaient argué non c'est on sait que
c'est que tout ça mis ensemble ça s'en
va et ça revient
elle est parti de la u parti
le soleil c'est vrai qu'on ne rate
jamais je crois qu'il a conduit de
l'entrée et s'est arrêté sur midi ouais
à cet instant précis où tu vas la coupe
ettu est parti et je suis parti de
pâques c'est vraiment le muppets
ils sont membres
la première fois vous avez fait l'amour
à trois c'est une valve a dit louise
jamais la c1 d'aucuns vous dit jamais
parce que si c'est un joker c'est le
vieux portable